jack is with us in Pennsylvania hey Jack
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show David is
an absolute honor to speak with you and
I would love to hear how you doing
better than I deserve sir how can I help
love it
hey Dave my wife when I came onto your
plan earlier this year we have to thank
you because it gave us the guidance we
needed I since February we paid off
$90,000 in student loans
way to go and yes thank you it's been
all over here looking ahead we have
another 65,000 to go but that money is
in my mother-in-law's name but we've
agreed to help and we'll probably do the
bulk majority of paying it off now it is
her doctor's opinion though that she is
now permanently disabled so we're
definitely interested in pursuing
disability forgiveness and I was just
wondering that any advice on that to
kind of ensure that we don't get tangled
up in any bureaucracy or any
technicalities to a snack us along the
way
it's like a lot of technicalities and
bureaucracy my experience with it is
through our people like you that I've
talked to obviously but on the people
who actually get the forgiveness due to
disability are the ones that persist you
have to push through the bureaucracy and
get every box checked and every I dotted
and every T crossed and not let up until
you do it's a $65,000 part-time job and
so the ones that have had the best and I
think it may actually be a a thing that
is a requirement but the ones that have
had the best usually takes about a year
is after she has been declared
permanently disabled and the federal
government has agreed with that meaning
they that she has applied for and
receiving SSI she's receiving her Social
Security disability now she's seeing
family she go ahead now she's currently
on the she's currently on the Social
Security but it's for the it's for the
which would be the next level down her
review on that though comes up in May
that being said from what I could read
on the on the website it looks like one
of the provisions if you meet it is a
physician's asportation that your that
you're disabled and she does have that
her doctor her doctor wrote her a note
already saying that she's permanently
disabled okay if that will do it and you
can get it pushed through then just
follow the directions on the website but
here's the thing you've got to follow up
you've got to pound them if not going to
assume they do their work its
bureaucrats they don't care they're
they're horrible at service and we all
know that I mean you didn't with the
federal government right so just don't
act like you can just send in the
application then five years later go I
wonder what happened to that you know
that's not going to work for you you're
gonna have to go put it in follow up put
it in follow up call them write them
email them hassle them find out what the
timeline is how long does this take
push it you know kindly and you know
yelling at somebody but work this
constant push this pressure on the
system and that's how you get things
done in a situation like that it's the
only way and so that that's what I'd
recommend and yes I would push that on
through as a parent plus holder if she's
become permanently disabled that loan
will be forgiven and it is one of the
two ways you get out of a student loan
die or become disabled and that's it Oh
third ways pay it off but hopefully
we're gonna be able to run this through
for her and you can take the point on it
you can even get a power of attorney
specific power of attorney if you need
to to act on her best and do the work
for her if you wanted to and specific to
this task in other words you would not
be able to do other things in her name
but just this task and that's not hard
to do it's a one-page document and so
all of that can can but but just someone
has to have make this their mission
until it's done and and it won't be
someone at the federal government you do
not have an advocate there you are the
Advocate